[Music]
you know there are many famous landmarks
here in chicago but none is more love
than the wiener circle
let's face it people love the wiener
circle
people go there for the chicago hot dogs
and also for the extremely
hostile staff see they put down the
customers who in turn
yell back at them it's a tradition it's
fun it's intense
it's very very vulgar all right we
thought as an experiment
we would send to the wiener circle the
nicest most polite person we
know jack mcbrear of 30 rides
such look at that face such a nice guy
we wanted to see how jack would handle
this incredibly
abusive environment here now
is his report
[Music]
[Music]
yeah hey conan
i'm here right outside the wiener circle
thanks so much for sending me here
um i'm real excited i've heard great
things and it looks like there's a lot
going on in there so come on let's go
check it out
[Applause]
do you want to charge
hey wipe
[Applause]
foreign
gingerbread
[Music]
very rude
i'm coming back with a friend and you
will be very sorry yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
a [ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah
skanky smurfs
you listen you listen to me queen la
queefa
listen to you and your mouth do you kiss
your pimp with that now
you know what they say what's wrong with
that
what's wrong with that that's perfectly
natural where he comes from
why are you so mean to this kid his
sisters used to tease him mercilessly
especially during sex
that's not true don't be ashamed
hey you know why you guys work for tips
because no one will stick the whole
thing in
that's nice oh yeah oh no
you didn't go to high school
oh no you didn't wash your ass today
oh no you didn't oh yeah
oh no you didn't yeah yeah yeah your
mama's
she and your daddy and your sister
coat and your uncle's mouth and that's
right
i said it and you know i'm gonna stick
my head
in the marble sofa where the faces fall
off and the jew says
you ain't all that that's what you gonna
take me out to the bargain
buy me some peanuts and cracker jack i
don't
even care if i ever come back joseph and
the amazing technicolor dream coat
fried green tomatoes steven
sisterhood of the traveling pants that's
right
america ferrara 800 588
2300 empire beach
why do you say hurtful things words
matter seriously seriously
yelling at people like this for a living
how do you sleep in your car at night
i didn't know tyler perry worked here
oh my god
especially carbohydrates
you're like nicki minaj minus the
everything
and we weren't for you no no we want to
show you how it's done
come on now we're coming in there and
showing you how it's done
you want a charm dog how about to shut
up with cheese
right walk away walk away [ __ ]
oh yeah fine it's on jack relish onions
disinfectant yeah i'll take a hot dog
shark jack take this guy i got to get
him out of here
do you want this wiener to go or would
you like to shove it up your ass right
here
very good very good okay
[Applause]
shut up it's good that's not bad
[ __ ] tip eggs
hey this put your hand down
[Applause]
yes
before you go
[Applause]
[Music]
understand
[Applause]
the wiener circle is a great place for
me to puke on